Dear doctor, assalamu allayikum.
I am Abdul Rashid from KQatar.
I need information about your Uru TV
channel.
I am not receiving it since 3 years ago
in Kqatar. I am getting this channel
information from Google 2. Is it running
or stopped?
Please send some information about Udu
TV channel whether it's available in
kqatar or not. The question posed by the
brother is that he has been watching
peace TV udu since a long time but since
3 years he's not getting the udu Islamic
channel. The name of the channel is
peace TV udu. So he's asking that is the
channel running? How can he see it?
Alhamdulillah we have got four satellite
channels which are 24 by7. Number one is
peace TV English. Number two is peace TV
Udu. Number three is peace TV Bangla.
And number four is peace TV Chinese. As
far as our satellite channels are
concerned, we see to it that we are
present on multiple satellites. The more
number of satellites you're present is,
more number of eyeballs, the more number
of people are watching. Our first
channel PTV English was launched in
2006. Then we launched peace TV Udu in
2009.
Then we launched peace TV Bangla in
2011. And we launched peace TV Chinese
in 2015.
As far as peace TV is concerned, peace
TV started in 2010. And since its
inception, it's growing. It's always
there. So you are not able to watch
peace TV in Qatar. Maybe your dish has
got shifted or the direction of your
dish this dish has shifted. As far as
katar is concerned, there are two
satellites which show puru. One is the
arabsat, the other is the intat 20. The
Arab sat is watched more by the Arabs
uno Arabic as a language. The non-Arabs
they watch other satellite and the other
famous satellite is that it is the
interrat 20. So alhamdulillah we are
present on both on Arabs which is very
famous among the Arab world. It covers
the whole of the Middle East. It covers
the whole of Europe and very beneficial.
But the peace TV is also seen on intera
20 which is seen more by the Asian
people the Indian the Pakistani and on
Asian set Asia 20 intera 20 sorry not
Asia interat 20 it is the satellite
which has the largest footprint it
covers more than 70% of the world
population it is seen in middle east
it's seen in India it's seen in the
Indian subcontinent print all the
countries that is uh Pakistan, Sri
Lanka, Bangladesh, Maldi etc. So peace
TV is present in kqatar since 2006.
The udu the peace TV the peace TV udu is
present in 2009 and even today is
present. Only thing you have to shift
your dish. So if you shift your dish in
the angle of 68° east then inshallah you
will be able to watch and see peace TV
udu. And recently or maybe four years
back we are even telecasting our peace
TV udu and peace TV English on paxat on
Pakistan set. So the brothers came they
set up and they went away but now it's
also available on paxat. Thus the
viewership of PTF has increased but
previously people only used to watch on
on the other platform. So the more
number of satellites that you are in a
particular region the more number of
eyeballs because Arab sat is mainly
watched by by the Arabs they don't watch
Asia sat or interrat. So that is the
reason that we started even Pakat so
that more of the UDU audience can watch.
So now at present we are on three
satellites and all three are covering
the Middle East and even covering
Singapore and also covering the other
countries. So the by this network
alhamdulillah PTV Uru is seen on three
satellites in Qatar that is Arabsat
Interat 20 as well as Assasat as 7. Hope
that answers the question.